tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
io son of a vigente oggi siamo in un
episodio di ruote felici perché è poi si
vuol dire ruote felici ci avete mai
pensato ricatti perché facciano da
essere felici se ruote costo minchia di
individuo qui comunque ragazzi che
lascia perdere andiamo avanti non va
bene veramente doveva ancora iniziare
per ora è luke che mi distrae ragazzi
non pensate ma che cos'è
oddio oh mio dio mio dio mio dio mio dio
perché sei pelato vabbè è questa la cosa
che mi sta che cazzo è successo a caso
va bene ok ragazzi non ancora iniziato
specco a sparare bello di voi la gamba
zio guarda ce l'ho io non avevo capito
ragazzi perché ti piace la zucca vero è
bello è bello come la muove bene e mi
piego hard ali come ti rende forte e
vigorosa la zucca ascolta zio tu che sei
sul sito chi cazzo sta facendo ragazzi
si stanno normando una colonna anno
perfetto senti zio non vorrei non voglio
essere contro di te prati lo smi
traviare come se non ci fosse un domani
perfetto prossimo non c'è nessuno vabbè
dai allora controllo ciò non si beve
mentre si sparava sardo eccolo lì
perfetto dispiace sono molto mi
rincresce che lotto in realtà non è
cattivo non operatori o che vuole solo
spaccarti la faccia come cazzo
stavo per fare una cosa epic stavo
palleggiando con quel bambino ok grazie
è stato è stato il livello più bello
degli ultimi tempi non so per
ok si stava esorcizzando il livello
ragazzi neon staircase che bello mi
piace oggi sono in vena di giocare più
visto non so perché pard hard tua mamma
zio non io che brutta cosa che ho detto
ma chi se ne fotte mai così agli
occupanti bravo luke fai vedere chi sei
distingui t come al solito non dovevo
scendere così vero e lo sapevo lo sapevo
il sellino di che hanno lasciato
indietro pazienza ho vinto ma che bravo
che sono frisullo ad haifa gianfry i
suoi che cazzo e presto z to play e va
bene devo fare i dovuti der scappi
collare barry fast si chiudono non ho
capito ho capito perché ciò la gamba
staccata dal corpo abbiamo capito
ragazzi devo andare lì sotto
praticamente vuole esistere prima che
che sismiche il muro fantastico e tatto
cosa sono appeso
[Musica]
forza è di far vedere che la dieta è
servita fai vedere che è servita bravo
zio poi di sotto io mio perfetto per non
perfetto un pene sui ma si incastra
tissimo e invece no perché ho fatto
dieta bravo giuseppe di che serve
imposti voci sono delle spade cazzo
bravo finiti al nulla ci provo e non lo
so non vi prometto niente a me erano
finti to roll ed io che c'è anche
creduto questa cosa bravo zio spezzati
da gamba alla fine che sei punti serve a
niente non so perché faccio così ogni
tanto mi faccio corre da solo da due
corse che bello ma che bello ma è
bellissimo the calma zio non stai cavo
che ti picchio bravo ma in fondo chi ha
bisogno di un collo quando sia liuc che
può andare al posto tuo balza li fai
vedere chi sei forza è un ei due è un
non denigro appare tuo padre che andrà
avanti zio che non hai capito niente
della vita che io vai a controllare che
sia tutto a posto per favore bravo
allora dovrebbe essere a posto perché
andiamo bravo che ciclista che ciclista
guarda che è tornato un braccio di luke
sul sedile a caso aggiornamento cazzo me
ne ha parecchi braccioni uk che
pericolosamente vicino al mio culo
lasciam perdere bravissimo ad onna
mister mi sta impressionando padre di
luke non ha un nome ancora dobbiamo
pagarcelo chiamassimo in qualche modo il
padre di uk tipo da va bene a padre di
uk e un nome giusto
eccoci spingi stronzo eccoci perfetto
bravo questo questo è arrivare a un
traguardo in modo sexy si vede che fa
yoga zio steegmans vai facciamo oggi
sono carini livelli non so perché liz
minchio tutti ma sono carichi e bello
che sei zio sai quel tocco di rosa che
mi farà pare come si deve ma che bello
eccoci qua ci siamo ma non ho saltato
tutto che fai zio l'ha spaccata
well a jack sparrow come stai sei una
merda fatelo dire cioè un casinò sta
minkia ma perché mi di infilzare il
deretano ma che cosa c'hai contro le mie
palle ma vaffan
ti stacchi ti stai staccando che mi dà
fastidio zio della ragazza un tizio
attaccato al culo abbiate pazienza
dammi la spinta che tu dammi la mano
bravo zio vedi che riusciamo così sono
incastra perché mi ha infilzato nel culo
tra tutti i punti con leo briaco branche
bello che da ubriaco mi spiace zio sento
distrutto la bottiglia però non si beve
mentre si gioca thanks for plain di slam
ma figurati sia un importante non avere
gente sul culo perfetto finito
l'importante è vincere la gara in kraft
boltro weber c'è milan ci mancava solo
questo praticamente lab e dai andiamo
avanti su wonder boys la madonna morte
morte morte voglio la morte piccone di
diamante
spiegatemi il senso doveva l'anti cazzo
ma cove moore ci credo mai perché ho
fatto a morire ma dai che inutile si
stronzo cioè proprio c'è scritto stronzo
nel cervello bravo zio o long firewall
mi mancano anche gli spike welcome to
land spyphone 6 fireplace enjoy
[Musica]
di morsa è tanto per restare in tema
danniamo col cavallo bello ragazzino non
è il cavallo più splendido che voi
abbiate mai visto in tutta la vostra
vita per me così che funziona ei sei un
caro a chi cazzo dici è il lurido roba
direi al mio cavallo un'altra volta e ti
stupro la famiglia ecco già fatto non
c'e neanche è stato bisogno di aspettare
già stuprata ragazzi voi non lo sapete
ma in realtà i cavalli sono persone
cattive ma veramente cattive soprattutto
questo molto cattivo
lancer vai proviamo questo ragazzo è
ancora perché mi manca mi salvai val che
cosa è successo c'era un look e oscuro
che ha ucciso il mio liuc è meglio così
challenge set ma ovvio 0 cena stati
tutti i cani perché vi denuncio tutti
quanti fatemi capire il senso c'è un
ragno un cazzo di rhind all'ascolto zio
chiese più belle ragno che io abbia mai
visto posso toccarti cosa ti aspetta che
ti prendono dove vai
vieni qui vieni qua eh sì sì in gruppi
amo cio ha sì lo so che mi vuoi se la
chiazza che roba triste farsi un ragno
acchiappa ragno tipo quando andavi alle
giostre che capì a chi ha poi cosa qua
chi apr scusa zio non volevo è così rai
fossero tutti così simpatici ma ci farei
anche amicizia prima che stavo
scherzando
stavo proprio evento scherzando sconta
zio e ho incontrato tuo figlio che
tendono ti è che nascondi pugnale come
assassin's creed sei stronzo vedi di
andare avanti come ma c'è un modo
semplice per far sì che bello bastava
andare veloci ditelo prima cosa che
hanno appena fatto
[Applauso]
un 360 d'andata oscar non è bravo zio
complimento adatto a testament ecco di
essere preso a pugni esatta slow slopes
lo slow browse lo bravissimo capito cosa
voglia dire marcia zio posso prendere la
moneta grazie è molto gentile
se osserva il mio culo per il resto
della partita ad apple default sarebbe
ragazzi la caduta però non capito che è
caduta devo fare ok dal the focus fin
qua ceo andiamo avanti che non è granché
servais a cosa o dio ho preso una rampa
che ascolta luke da una tranquilla
natura non avere da non ti far venire da
vomitare adesso non tifa cazzo cacciavo
schiacciava ragazzi non so come si robe
a caso vecchio ragazzi problema un paio
di miei livelli perché ancora non ho
visto roba seria ultimamente perfetto
per i j the games maggiori giochi di fa
vj hai mai notato che ostuni a sei
lettere un multiplo di tre che ricorda
vagamente le punte di un triangolo
illuminati con ford
ragazzi mi avete mai notato che l'occhio
degli illuminati e circolare proprio
come la lettera o di ostuni questo
livello parla di tutti o quasi tutti i
giochi di fa vj prova di tutti che cazzo
sono tipi poche ma la chiappa di tutti
happy with non so neanche che cosa ho
scelto perché non ho letto niente però è
giusto quindi va bene così
attenzione non tutti i blocchi sono veri
alla sei stronzo come faccio a saperlo
questo è vero questo non è vero è adesso
morto
la vita è fatta di cose tristi c'è crisi
per trovare lavoro si fa di tutto con
babbo natale il tizio dio che senso ha
una roba invece cosa fai non piega amico
non volevo treat arti maroni stai
scusami cibo gratis
il boss il boss è un bidone il boss di
vidoni su mtv è una roba indecente me va
bene ragazzi ho portato il boss fino al
traguardo
la mia vita è fottutamente completa
prova un ultimo ragazzi che è un imposti
col che riuscirò a fare anche al primo
tentativo perché io l'ho imposto io
facciamo al secondo perché io di imposti
con l'hiv e nintendo legame nintendo non
intendo nintendo che cazzo di salto era
questo
[Musica]
ogni fatto ragazzi me ne esco queste
cose che non so manco io come ho fatto
perfetto sì sì sì ok ok non so non
fatemi domande non ne ho la più pallida
idea non so come ho fatto non lo voglio
sapere
la vj e bic wrestling l'ultima che
faccio e poi basta perché perché gli
stai succhiando i capezzoli ragazzi
concluso qui il video direi che è il
livello più strano che abbia mai fatto
perché gesù santo spiegami il senso di
toccare la buddi a un obeso sei vite
piaciuto solite lasciato il momento mi
piace anche a pagina di facebook e come
la novità o trattare la descrizione
cesaristi discreti noi ci vediamo il
prossimo lì dove le ragazze